Argentina o Croacia uno de esos dos
equipos será finalista de este mundial
de Qatar 2022 Pero antes tendrán que
pasar por la gran prueba de ese partido
de semifinal un partido que se anuncia
bastante complicado para ambos partidos
y en el que los argentinos de hecho ya
han dicho que están listos para Sufrir
sufrir ante un bloque defensivo croata
que ha demostrado esa fortaleza que se
ha demostrado cada vez más aguerrido y
algo que de hecho alabó leonar el
escalón y el director técnico de la
albiceleste por ese espíritu de equipo
que tiene el equipo de tlaco por su
parte los croatas no ven este partido
como Croacia frente a Messi sino en
realidad Ven a la Argentina como todo un
conjunto con muy buenos jugadores ahora
está también es la oportunidad para
volver de Tal vez para la Argentina de
tomar revancha porque esta es la tercera
vez que los equipos se enfrentan en un
Mundial la última vez no fue hace mucho
fue en Rusia 2000 18 y en ese entonces
Croacia ganó tres goles a cero Esto fue
en la fase de grupos pero desde entonces
las cosas han cambiado Estos son dos
equipos distintos no están los mismos
jugadores y hasta modrić sí está Messi
Pero entre tanto Pues también Argentina
ha venido tomando mucha más fuerza es el
ganador de la Copa América y desde
entonces la albiceleste pues ha tomado
digamos mucho más abuelo como sea pues
el ganador de este partido se enfrentará
al ganador de la otra semifinal que
tendremos el miércoles eso será
Marruecos ante Francia y la oportunidad
de los croatas sobre todo de poder Si
llegan a la final de tomar revancha
Ojalá como ellos mismos lo dicen contra
Francia